Donald Trump increasingly seeming unwell
posting uncontrollably to truth social
multiple times per hour about Fox news
about Ron DeSantis about rhinos about
CPAC Trump seems to have nothing to do
other than to rage and melt down day
after day hour after hour look at the
last 24 hours for Trump on Truth sensual
whatever you call it Trump's starting
yesterday with quote I think that fox
board member Rhino Paul Ryan put his
boss Rupert Murdoch in a great legal and
monetary Jeopardy by convincing him to
go against his news anchors and their
belief that the 2020 presidential
election was rigged and Stalin it was
Stalin in so doing Murdoch is saying
that fox behaved badly when in fact
evidence has proven that the election
was Rife with election fraud and
irregularities Ryan is bad luck for Fox
he should resign or be fired too many
incompetent rhinos at Fox News this this
is freaking brilliant we have all of the
texts that show that the fox hosts
didn't really believe Trump won this is
what's so amazing about Trump's ability
to just ignore critical realities about
the world around us Trump wants to make
the case all those Fox hosts rightly
believed that I won but Rupert Murdoch
and Paul Ryan convince them otherwise
um the truth is the anchors were
publicly playing up this whole it was
stolen narrative or it was Stalin As
Trump wrote
but privately they were texting each
other about how it was all BS so they
didn't really believe it that's the
reality but of course so far Rhino Paul
Ryan Rupert Murdoch that's the the
target of Trump's ire Trump then moving
on to talking about polling talking in
uh speaking typing in all caps great
poll numbers leading Biden de Sanctus
and all others by a lot make America
great again okay so going after Rhonda
Santos and Biden Trump continuing now
moving on to CPAC Now understand the
context CPAC is a joke this year last
night I tried to stream day one there
were no live streams it seems like they
canceled day one like it's it's in
shambles at CPAC Trump is speaking there
on Saturday and Trump is I guess angry
that a lot of people aren't going there
or something so Trump posts I will be at
CPAC on Saturday talking about the fact
that obviously our Capital C country is
going to quote unquote hell and how to
fix it also the Democrats use of radical
left prosecutors and the weaponization
of law enforcement it is illegal has
never been used and abused like this and
has the potential to bring down our once
fair and wonderful Capital C country
these marxists cap Marxist capital T
thugs have been after me for years only
to help them win elections in just
Capital two Capital years we have become
a third world Capital failing capital N
Nation Maga so just dissembling
completely just his brain is mush Trump
continuing now addressing why many
aren't going to CPAC the only reason
certain quote candidates won't be going
to CPAC is because the crowds have no
interest in anything they have to say
they've heard it all before and don't
want to hear it again but my speech on
Saturday night is already a sold out
monster they are trying to expand the
room in space we'll have a great time at
CPAC we always do
see you there and don't forget to vote
in the important straw poll now one of
the reasons a lot of people aren't going
to CPAC is that cpac's um uh the guy who
runs CPAC match lap is Accused despite
being anti-gay is accused of sexually
assaulting a male staffer of Herschel
Walkers back during the campaign I I
know that the language is sort of
colorful but he's accused the word that
was used is pummeling the junk of one of
these staffers and a lot of a lot some
Republicans seem to want nothing to do
with match slap okay couple more posts
and again this is all within a day Trump
is just uncontrollably post truth
essential quote rumors are flying high
that idiot Rhino Paul Ryan who has
greatly hurt The credibility of Rupert
Murdoch with his ridiculous stance that
the 2020 election was all peaches and
cream will be fired like a dog from the
fox board Fox is going in the wrong
direction ratings are heading down and
Murdoch just through certain very good
people who were correct under the bus he
played right into the enemy's Camp
viewers and Maga are not happy and then
lastly Trump posting Rupert Murdoch
should apologize to his viewers and
readers for his ridiculous defense of
the 2020 presidential election how many
forms of cheating and rigging does he
have to see he should also apologize to
those anchors who got it right and fire
the ones who got it wrong or were afraid
to speak up of which there were many
it's time to get rid of fake news and
call it like it is
fascinating Trump now applying his fake
news moniker his fake news moniker to
Fox News itself it is going to be a wild
primary my intent is to stream CPAC
today tomorrow and Saturday assuming it
doesn't get canceled like last night
seemed to get we will be starting mid to
late afternoon 4 5 pm eastern-ish today
on YouTube twitch and Facebook I hope
you'll join me and remember our our
commentary and videos widely available
on Tick Tock search David packman show
on tick tock
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at fair prices guys
know it can be very tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts the search is over
because all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
super lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up and it's also great for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
really great supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts less than one percent of men's
Basics today are made with supima cotton
it is the best out there it feels like
Silk quite frankly you can walk around
in a scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair trade and made sustainably go pick
up the most comfortable t-shirts and
boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below